south africa has responded calling this
decision to ban flights temporarily as
rushed how would you respond to that
well look i think we know from dealing
with coronavirus all this time that
actually the kind of early bird catches
the worms as it were it's important to
make sure that you do act immediately
and in doing so you get to slow things
down in terms of potential entry into
the country and that gives us a bit of
time for the scientists to work on uh
sequencing the genome which involves
growing cultures and takes several weeks
to do so we can find out how significant
concern this particular variant is so it
is a safety first uh approach we've done
that before with things like the mink
variant from denmark and we're then able
to relax it a unreasonably quickly and i
think it's a preference for doing that
rather than waiting and seeing until
it's too late
but but between five and 700 people fly
to the uk every day from south africa
alone what about those people who
arrived in the last 24 hours and who
could be carrying that variant already
yeah i should say we haven't actually
detected any in the uk at all as yet um
but we're contacting those people
specifically that works already underway
uh to make sure that they're taking pcr
tests and we're getting the extra uh
checks um done so we're able to contact
each of those individuals through the
passenger locator form of course if
you're watching this and you have
returned from south africa uh then
please be in contact with test and trace
please take a pcr test um straight away
and they will be contacting you uh but
uh you know we just thought that
this is a
as scientists have described a uh the
most significant variant they've
encountered to date in their uh research
and i want to actually thank the south
african uh government for um their great
work in helping to uncover this is very
much a precautionary approach but i
think it makes sense and i think that
the wider population will will uh sort
of appreciate that we're acting quickly
because we don't want to have the chance
of uh we want to give ourselves every
opportunity uh to be able to research
this uh before it uh becomes uh you know
common here
now
it suggested that vaccines could be 40
less effective against this new variant
you say you're contacting people and
inviting them for a pcr test these tests
won't be enforced
then so the that we certainly will be um
uh contacting every single person who's
coming back and asking for a test
remember that it's still a relatively
small outbreak uh in south africa uh but
that is growing very very quickly so we
need to learn about the severity of the
transmissibility of it uh and of course
most critically of all how vaccines
susceptible it is in other words whether
it can escape the vaccine or not um but
we're tracking down each person who's
who's come here as i say we we've got no
signs that it's here yet uh it's still
relatively small in south africa but
this precautionary approach similar to
the one we took with the mink variant in
denmark i think is the right way to go
whilst we get answers you could i i hope
this simply becomes a pause in uh travel
uh from south africa and those other uh
countries uh but we do need to do this
work first and this is the precautionary
approach to make sure we have time to do
it
now we're very fortunate here the uk is
moving fast with booster vaccines unlike
uh the situation in many countries in
the developing world is vaccine
inequality one of the main reasons that
we're seeing the emergence of these new
variants
well i think um the united kingdom's got
a very proud record with that oxford
astrazeneca vaccine because that's the
one that globally has been distributed
particularly to the developing world
faster than uh any other um i i've got a
recent figure the last one i saw was a
billion and a half doses of it um being
uh distributed um and of course it's
being done at cost because astrozenica
said they wouldn't make a profit from um
doing it and of course it was it was
british
expertise at oxford university so i
think this country um has done a
remarkable amount as well as putting
money into the international vaccine
program as well uh perhaps dare i say
more than any other country given
the distribution of that cost vaccine to
the whole world
now one of the reasons uh variants are
detected so well in south africa is
because they have such great
genomic sequencing we can't be 100 sure
that this variant isn't already in the
uk or indeed within europe so why does
the government not uh enforce uh face
masks in areas such as public transport
or in shops like we see in so many other
countries
well one of the things that's kind of
interesting here is that we've seen
because as you rightly say the huge
take-up of vaccines very little um sort
of skepticism about vaccines in this
country unlike unlike elsewhere but this
bacteria may not be effective against
this new variant be far less effective
and that that is of course the concern
but i was going to say and the booster
uptake it's now touching on nearly 30
percent of people have had their
boosters you can't even have that until
it's six months after your uh first
vaccine but the uptake has been so good
that we have created a
something of a wall of protection now we
do have a plan b which is is well
publicized that if we need to go to that
we we will and that includes uh mark
squaring uh everywhere and the like uh
and and more besides but we don't want
we want people to be able to live their
lives we want the economy to be able to
flourish we want people to be able to go
about their business and see their
friends and family so we're trying to
operate as permissive
you know atmosphere as possible uh but
of course we're keeping a very close eye
on this all the time so far in our
numbers we haven't seen any reason to do
anything else and it has to be said
considering we've been unlocked since
the 19th of july
that i think we've been right to go
about in in this way
and you know
fortunately
the figures move around uh there are
certainly plenty of cases each day but
those cases are translating into
hospitalizations and deaths at a much
lower rate
than elsewhere